so wait do you have something planned
with my band today i heard that you did
and i'm very excited
yeah you're missing something in the
show and i i think that uh
a theme song you don't have a theme song
oh i don't ever think
we have worked up a few theme songs
for you all right can i hear you wanna
tell me about one maybe sing one or i
don't know
let's just sing it let's sing it okay
let's do it
you have not given me permission to use
these as my thing i'm just saying
because i love it i'm excited
it's time time to watch some gallery
kelly on the deli it's the kelly
clarkson show
you talk about that all right all right
i liked it i felt the vibe i liked it
i love it i have a feeling i'm gonna
want all of them
it's for sale i'm gonna literally have i
want all of them to
like for different people that call
because i feel like you have a few and i
want all of them
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help